[snorts]
>> This man, his name is Gay Talese.
This year he's 94 years old. He's still
going strong. This is wife, Nan Talese.
For decades they were the first couple
of American literature in New York City.
And I'm very proud to have him as my
mentor.
So,
about 30 years ago,
um I was in Beijing. I had just
graduated from Yale College. I was
working as a high school teacher.
But I wanted to become a writer. I was
an English literature major at Yale.
And so, um I met some journalist friends
who introduced me to Gay Talese.
In the summer of '99, he came to Beijing
to work on a story. And he needed a
translator. So, I became his translator
for 6 months.
And during those 6 months, I received
the best education any young writer
could receive from the greatest American
writer of his generation.
He [snorts] practices an art called
literary
journalism.
And no one else
practices this the way he does.
>> [snorts]
>> So, what he does is that
he will spend hours and hours just
talking with someone, trying to get to
know this person,
trying to understand the world from this
person's perspective.
And then, after spending days, months
with that person, and talking to other
people around him or her,
he will try to draw out a memory
from that person and put it in words
uh in a way that resonates with uh his
audience.
And he is a genius.
And when I mean he's a genius, I mean he
is unique in what he does. Every writer
we've read this semester, whether it's
Homer or Dante, uh even Gay Talese, who
we'll read him today, they are unique in
what they do.
Harold Bloom, the great American
literary critic, says that great
literature is shocking.
You read it and you are shaken by it in
a way that you remember forever. It is a
deep emotional experience that stays
with you for entire life. It shakes you
in a way that forces you to reorientate
your worldview. It forces you to better
understand who you are, your place in
the world, and your understanding of the
world. And that's what Gay Talese does.
What he does is unique. No one else does
what he does. No one else can do what he
does, and it is shocking. It is shocking
because it transcends
time
and space.
Okay?
His writing are able to transcend the
uh time he's writing uh in and then
spread across different cultures. So, we
we will not fully appreciate his genius
maybe until 50 years from now, 100 years
from now.
Okay? So, he is mainly known
for his journalism.
He is the greatest journalist of his
generation, probably the greatest
journalist of all time. Uh American
journalism is dying, so
people like him will no longer be able
to work.
The These are his boxes. What's amazing
[snorts] about his boxes is that they
are living souls, okay? You can't really
see it because the picture quality isn't
great, but what he does is that he turns
each box into a unique soul with own
time, its own place, its own memories.
He uses his box boxes in order to create
articles and essays and books.
Okay? So, he takes
um
memories of life, real memories of life,
and turns them into great works of
literature. He is mainly known for
um
his book
The Kingdom and the Power, which is
about the New York Times. If you work at
the New York Times, you still read that
book today as a young journalist.
Uh he wrote a book called Honor Thy
Father, which is about the American
Mafia.
And he wrote an essay magazine article
called Frank Sinatra Has a Cold, which
is considered the greatest American
magazine essay ever written.
Today, I want to talk about a work that
people don't really discuss about Gay
Talese. It's called Thy Neighbor's Wife.
Oh,
yeah, Thy Neighbor's Wife.
>> [snorts]
>> And
this is a book that is one of the
best-selling American books of all time.
It sold millions of copies. It made him
filthy rich. Um
It made millions of dollars.
At the same time, it basically destroyed
his career because
um in the late '70s, when this book was
published he was a really respected
journalist writer he was a celebrity and
he was married to a beautiful book
editor editor named Nantalise who will
go on to have a spectacular publishing
career.
And when you're famous
as an American in the 70s there are
certain ways you have to behave. Okay?
You have to respect rules and
conventions. You have to respect taboos.
And at the height of his fame and this
is like his you know like mid-40s he
decides to do something that completely
went against
the convention the rules morality of
that time.
He [snorts] decided to write a book on
sex.
>> [snorts]
>> And there have been lots of books
published published about sex before but
the way he decided to go write about
this book was itself unconventional. He
decided to write about sex he needed to
go into the heart of darkness itself. He
needed to explore the deepest darkest
most depraved secrets of humans.
Okay?
Um and so he would spend at least 10
years
engaging all sorts of like really
strange activities which famous men
should not do in public, okay? Yes, I
understand rich famous men are
hypocrites and they do this in private
but they don't do it in public and let
the whole whole whole world know about
it and don't certainly write a book
about it, okay? But the guy decides to
become a manager at a massage parlor.
He will go to California and engage in
orgies.
He will masturbate with
uh other man
but he is an anthropologist.
He is trying to understand
the
complexity
of
humans. And to do that, you first need
to appreciate sex.
Okay? So, this is a book that no one
talks about because it is so
controversial. It is so disturbing. It's
disturbing because it's truthful.
All right?
Because it tells us that human beings
are ultimately animals.
Um and so, I think this is
one most courageous books ever written
because it puts a mirror to us and shows
us that we're just basically monkeys.
But at the same time, it's also one of
the most enlightening, inspiring books
that we've written because that has ever
been written because if you look at the
act of sex of human beings, it's
different from animals because
ultimately what lies behind sex is
religion.
Our need, our search for God.
Ultimately, that's why we have sex. If
you actually read this anthropological
study of sex, then you understand that
we humans are first and fundamentally
religious
beings
that seek to return to God. That's
something that Homar and Donna has
talked about before
in the past, right? Okay. So, before we
go into The Naked Ape's Wife and explore
how it's fundamentally a book about
religion, I'm going to go into some um
occult
mysticism, okay?
So, this is something called Kabbalah.
The Kabbalah
means to receive.
The Kabbalah is an understanding
of how the universe works, why we're
here,
where we came from, where we're going.
Okay, this called the tree of life.
And the story is this. In the beginning,
God is everything.
It's pure energy.
And God wants to know itself.
God wants to complete itself.
God wants to extend itself. And so, what
it does is it creates a new being called
Adam Kadmon, okay? Think of Adam Kadmon
as
the cosmic man.
The first cosmic man.
And God is the will to bestow. God is
love, generosity, forgiveness. So, God
wants to extend himself
onto Adam Kadmon. And to do that, he
creates Adam Kadmon as the will to
receive, okay?
The will to receive.
God is the will to bestow. Adam Kadmon
is the will to receive.
But, the problem with this is that as
the will to receive, Adam Kadmon is pure
ego.
And so, he doesn't really appreciate why
God is so generous with him, why God is
willing willing to bestow his essence
onto him. So, Adam Kadmon
rejects God because he's full of doubt.
He's skeptical. He's scared. He's
embarrassed. Okay? And this ultimately
leads to something called the breaking
the shattering of a vessels.
Shattering the vessels. All right? So,
what happens is that this is the tree of
life, which is basically Adam Kadmon.
All right? And as God is trying to pour
his essence into Adam Kadmon, Adam
Kadmon turns away. And so, what happens
is that light spills outside the tree of
life, okay? And this sparks of divinity,
sparks of divinity, scattered across the
world. And this breaks the world.
So,
as a result, this leads to sin, death in
our world. So, in order for us to repair
the world,
what we need to do is collect
those sparks
that have spilled over from the tree of
life, and then
let and then combine together, repair
the vessel, so that God may come to our
world and reunify with us.
Okay? So, according to Jewish mysticism,
that is the purpose of life.
All right? So,
this is a very basic understanding of
the Kabbalah,
which helps us understand our place in
the world and why we're here to do what
what we do. Now, there are three things
I need you guys to remember about the
tree of life, okay?
The first thing to remember about the
tree of life is that it's sexual in
nature.
Okay?
So, the idea is that two forces are
combining to create a new force.
Right? So, God is the will
to bestow
and Adam Kadmon is the will to receive.
So this is a divine fundamental force to
sex.
Okay?
You've been taught that it's a dirty
thing, but in fact, it's a very
fundamental force of the universe.
Okay? And because the world is sexual,
it moves in certain logic.
Okay? And the logic is this.
You start off with a being
who creates another being in order to
complete itself.
Okay? And this leads to a new being
which then creates another being, which
creates another being.
Okay?
And this is the tree of life.
In other words, the tree of life is the
fundamental
movement of the universe.
And we can also frame it as
thesis
synthesis Oh, sorry. Thesis, antithesis
and synthesis.
Okay, that's number two. Okay? This is a
fundamental logic of the universe.
And the third thing that we need to
appreciate is that
our mission on Earth
our journey, our purpose is to repair
the world by saving the sparks of light.
Okay? The sparks of light are
fragments
of God, memories of God that are now
scattered across the world. The problem
is that as they become scattered in the
world, they become enveloped by
husk, okay? Material things. Husk.
And we call these like the body, right?
So, in other words, our spirit in the
spirit inside us, it's divine, but we're
covered by our body, which is the husk.
And as as a result, we're blinded
by our material desires.
Okay?
And so, this is a fundamental conflict
in the universe. How do we go about
repairing the world? Well, we go about
repairing the world by repairing
ourselves, by discovering the light
inside of us.
All right?
And so, this is the question
that Gay Talese is going to undertake.
What he's going to do is that he's going
to risk his entire career. He did He did
actually risk his entire career. And
he's going to go into the deepest,
darkest corners of the human heart
to figure out how we can
um
liberate our divine aspects from the
husk that has imprisoned it.
Okay? That is the fundamental conflict
driving the book Thy Neighbor's Wife.
All right? And if you read the book,
three different solutions
are being proposed.
Okay? Three different solutions
are being proposed
to answer this mystery.
The first solution is
meditation.
Okay? Meaning that we ourselves have the
energy, the power to liberate our spark
from our husk through intense
consultation.
Okay?
But in a sexual sense, what is
meditation? Meditation is masturbation.
I know this sounds really weird. Okay, I
know this is going to be disturbing for
some of us, but it will make sense when
we get to the passage. Okay? I'm just
building the framework, the theory for
when we read Thy Neighbor's Wife. Okay?
So, that's a first solution. Second
solution
is to embrace sex.
Okay. So, the theory here is that
sex is meant to be free, to be casual,
to be joyous.
But society has imposed restrictions on
sex. So, sex is a mechanism to control
your feelings, to imprison your soul.
Okay? Because sex is taboo. So, for
example,
if you were to get married,
you're not supposed to sleep with other
people who who is not your wife or your
husband.
If you do so,
you have betrayed your wife, yourself,
and society as a whole.
And then you ask yourself,
"Well, why is that that important?
Why
is sex and love
really the same thing? So, what if you
have sex with another person? Why does
that matter?
Why can't you separate your husk from
your soul? Your soul can belong to
another person, but your hus can be a
joy can be enjoyed with other people.
Okay? And the way to liberate people
from this convention, from this taboo,
is to fully embrace sex. Okay? The more
sex there is between different people,
the more they recognize that what
matters is not the sex, what matters is
the love. Okay? Through sin,
you can break the taboo.
You can liberate yourself from the
taboo. When you liberate yourself from
the taboo, you liberate your soul.
Okay? And then your soul can then
reconnect with God.
So, there's a second solution proposed
in Thy Neighbor's Wife. And the third
solution
is
to recognize that the world, as
constructed, is perfect. It's not
broken, it's perfect. It's not
malfunctioning, it's doing exactly what
it should be doing. Why? Because we're
here not to find
the sparks of light, we're here to
create sparks of light.
And how can we do so? We can do so
through love and the imagination.
Okay?
We're not here to return to God, we're
here to do what God cannot do, extend
the boundaries of the universe by using
our imagination.
By creating memories that are
transcendental, that travel beyond time
and space, and which are able to inspire
others to imagine and to dream as well.
Okay? And this is the idea of Dante.
>> [snorts]
>> So, you have three radical visions of
what it means to seek liberation.
You have three radical visions of what
it means
to free your soul and to be one with
God.
Okay?
All right. But, the argument I want to
make you to make to you today is that
Thy Neighbor's Wife is a great book.
The reason why millions have read it,
the reason why that even though it was
written 50 years ago, we we still read
it and resonate with it is because
regardless if these paths fail or
succeed, they do resonate with us
because they remind us of our
fundamental need to return to God. Okay?
They remind us of who we are. And that's
why
uh Thy Neighbor's Wife is such a is
still such a beautiful and divine book.
All right. Okay. So, what we're going to
do is we're going to look at all three
different solutions together. Okay, so
the first is meditation through
masturbation.
All right. So, this is
um chapter one. And this is a man named
Harold Rubin.
And Harold Rubin, at this stage, he is a
teenager living in a very abusive
household. He's not happy where he he
is. He seeks escape. The way he seeks
escape is that he falls in love with a
woman named Diane Weber.
The problem though is that Diane Weber
is really not a person.
Diane Weber is a model
who poses nude on beaches. And Harold
Rubin will masturbate to the
um
uh nude pictures of Diane Weber. So,
what we're what we're going to read a
couple of paragraphs from the story of
Harold Rubin in Thy Neighbor's Wife. And
what I want you to focus on is the fact
that this act of masturbation is really
one of devotion.
Okay? Religious devotion.
You can read this and think that here
Reuben is a priest in a temple and he's
working very meticulously,
very carefully in order to create a
sacrifice,
a devotion worthy of God.
Okay? So, don't think of this as a
sexual scene, think of this as a
religious scene.
He's masturbating, but what he's really
doing is he's offering himself to his
God.
Okay?
A lean, dark-eyed woman on page four
attracted Harold, but the first
photographer had posed her awkwardly on
a narrow branch of a tree and he felt
her discomfort. Okay, this is really
interesting sentence. What he's is
saying is this,
when Harold Reuben is reading
or looking at pornography,
it is an act of
giving. It's an act of empathy.
And so, what he's seeking is not control
or power, what he's seeking is to be
with this woman that he's looking at.
Okay? It's an act of empathy, it's an
act of imagination. So, if she feels
discomfort, he also feels discomfort as
well. That is what religious devotion
really is about, giving yourself
completely to God in a way that you open
your heart and your soul to God. Okay?
Uh the nude on page six, sitting
cross-legged on a studio floor next to
uh easel, had fine breasts but a bland
expression on her face.
Okay? So, it's like Harold is having a
conversation
with each of these
people. His imagination is creating
a person in front
of him in order to have a dialogue.
So, it's not it's not just sexual
attraction, it's also dialogue in search
of mutual understanding.
Harrow still on his back with knees
slightly raised under blanket continued
to turn the pages past various legs and
breasts, hips and buttocks in here,
female fingers and arms reaching out,
eyes looking away from him, eyes looking
at him as he occasionally paused to
lightly stroke his genitals with his
left hand, tilting the magazine in his
left in his right hand to eliminate the
slight glare on the glossy pages.
So, we skip a bit. And then there were
those extremely weird pictures, those of
Diane Webber that could fulfill him
constantly. He estimated that his
collection contained 50 photographs of
her and within a moment he could locate
every one of them in the 200 magazines
that he kept. He would merely have to
glance at the cover and would know
exactly where she was within, how she
was standing, what was in the
background, what her attitude seemed be
doing during that split special split
second when the camera had clicked. He
could remember too first seeing these
pictures, could reconstruct where and
when he had bought them, he could
practically mark a moment in his life
from each of her poses, each being so
real that he believed he knew her
personally, she was part of him and
through her had become more in touch
with himself in several ways, not merely
through acts which Victorian moralists
had defined as self-abuse, but rather
through self-acceptance, his
understanding that naturalness of his
desires and of asserting his right to an
idealized woman, okay? So, think back to
the Kabbalah.
What is God? God is trying to bestow
himself onto us. We receive him
completely, this creates a union which
allows us to understand ourselves and
understand the universe. Okay? So, this
is exactly describing the Kabbalah,
where because Hero Rubin has been
meditating on Diane Weber for years, so
much so that she's become part of him,
this is has allowed him to better
understand himself
as well as his sexuality.
Okay?
Not able to resist any longer, Hero
turned the page to Diane Weber on the
dune. He looked at her lying on her
stomach, her head held up into the wind,
her eyes closed, the nipple on her left
breast erect, her legs spread wide, the
late afternoon sun casting exaggerated
shadow of her curvaceous body along the
smooth white sand. Beyond her body was
nothing but a sprawling empty desert.
She seemed so alone, so possible and
available. Hero had many desire her, and
she was his. Okay? So, this is a climax.
So, this is what sex is for humans. Sex
for humans is not about pleasure. It's
fundamentally about discovering who you
are and
creating a reunion between yourself and
other person so that you dissolve each
other and become one and the whole.
Okay? So, again, I understand this is a
scene about masturbation, but what makes
this genius, what makes this beautiful
and divine is
it's really
a description of religious devotion.
Okay? So, the greatness of this writing
is to show us that sex at its height,
sex at its fundamental level, is really
about religious worship.
Right?
Um
But, as you read this book, what you
recognize is that Hero Rubin,
ultimately, he lives a fantasy.
Because
even though it sounds great that through
meditation you can become one with God,
it doesn't really work. And so, what
happens that here Reuben will actually
never meet Diane Weber
because
he was just one of her life. And one
major reason why he will never meet
Diane Weber is because he's too afraid
to meet Diane Weber, okay? Diane Weber
is not a real person. It's just a
fantasy. He does not want to meet the
real Diane Weber because because meeting
her would shatter his fantasy and thus
shatter his religion.
Okay? So, this is one solution. It
doesn't really work. Meditation doesn't
really work. Another solution
is
uh proposed by John Williamson. Uh
sorry.
John Williamson, okay? And his wife
Barbara Williamson. And what they're
going to do is they're going to create a
sex cult together.
And
his understanding is this.
Modern society has made everyone
miserable.
Why has it made everyone miserable?
Because we're always lying to ourselves.
Because we're always repressed. We know
we don't like the jobs we do. We know
that we didn't learn anything in school.
We know that the person we married to we
don't actually like.
Okay? And so, we are in We have
imprisoned our soul in the husk. This
society that enforces a husk onto us.
So, the path to liberation means to
break out of this husk. And how do you
break out of this husk? By engaging in
sex.
To remove the power of sex over you,
right? Because in our society sex is
about shame.
Right? So, what he's going to do is he's
going to create a cult in which married
couples come together and have sex with
other people. And this will liberate
them from from the limitations of
marriage. And so, when you get rid of
the social convention, what is left is
your love for either yourself or for
your partner. And if there's no love,
then that's good because you will know
that you've been living a lie all this
time.
Okay? So, what he's going to do what is
is first create this group. And so, he's
going to recruit individuals
in order to join his cult. And the first
one of the first people he he recruits
is John Balero.
And his wife is named
um
Judith.
And they are
in a conventional marriage, which is to
say that they are
they are in a unhappy marriage where
they do what they're supposed to do.
John Balero goes, makes good money as an
insurance salesman. Judith is at home
taking care of the kids. So, they do
what they're supposed to do, but it's
unhappy. And so, John Wilsen knows he's
unhappy, and he arranges for John Balero
to have
affairs.
First with his wife, Barbara.
Uh and then with other people as well.
And then what he's going to do is that
he's going to invite both John Balero
and Judith to his house
where John Balero is going to have sex
with
um another woman
in another room.
And Judith is going to be beside is
going to be in another room listening in
on her husband having sex.
Okay? And this is a very disturbing
scene. And it's so disturbing, we're not
going to read it together, okay? But if
you're interested in reading it for
yourself, then you can pause the um um
video and read it. Okay? But what But
ultimately what happens is that John
Bileros having sex, Judith screams.
But the scream, it is considered
cathartic. It's therapeutic because the
screaming allows you to purge yourself
of your fears, of your ego, and your
fear.
Okay?
You now see that your husband is no
longer yours.
You You lose your fear because you
recognize that
your fear that your husband will run
away, will leave you, well, he's already
done so. Okay? So, when you leave your
ego and your fear, what happens is the
only thing that remains is who you
really are, which is the divine spark.
Okay? Divine spark. That's a theory
anyway, okay? It doesn't It doesn't
happen this way, but this is a theory.
All right?
So,
then what happens is that a few nights
later,
um
they do it again. John Bileros goes to
this house
and
he's having sex with another woman,
and Judith is in the room,
>> [snorts]
>> um listening in, okay? But instead of
just like listening and screaming, she
decides she's going to have sex with
John Williamson, because now her soul is
liberated. She's now free. She doesn't
care about um losing her husband, she
doesn't care about being mocked by other
people. So, she just She just engages,
she indulges in her passion, and she has
sex with
John Williamson. Okay?
Then,
John Bilero
hears the sex, he comes out, and he is
startled, he's traumatized to find
his wife
be having sex with another man.
Okay? And again, uh you can pause the
video and read the scene. It's a very
powerful scene.
And
he is shattered, okay? But this
shattering is good because it allows you
to repair yourself. You Once your ego
and your fear dissipate, you can now
resurrect yourself as you truly are.
Okay? Again, this is a theory.
[laughter] I'm not saying this works.
I'm Guys, don't try this at home, okay?
But this is a theory. And guess what,
guys? It doesn't work.
It doesn't work because maybe for the
first couple of times it works with
people, but when you actually try this
at scale, it kind of
um screws up. So, John Williamson
decides to take his religion and spread
to as many people as possible. So, he
sets up a retreat called the Sandstone
Retreat. Sandstone Retreat.
>> [snorts]
>> And it's basically just a sex club,
okay?
And when you And so, Gay Talese will go
to the sex club and spend a lot of time
there. And he writes this scene about
this sex club of like these They're just
having orgies all the time.
And we know it doesn't work because one
day Gay Talese sees John Williams John
Williamson
looking at a very strong, handsome,
muscular black man having sex with his
wife, Barbara. And it freaks him out,
okay?
So, the theory is great. Oh, if we just
sin enough,
we will absolve ourselves of our guilt,
of our fear, and that will truly
liberate us. But in practice, the
opposite happens. In practice, what
happens is that when you engage in sin,
the guilt compounds itself. So, the
theory is to remove
the husk, okay, the husk, so that the
soul can be liberated. But when you
engage in the material world, when you
have too much sex, the husk just extends
itself, and you become truly blind.
Okay? And this is why, even though John
Wilson succeeds in starting a sex cult,
even though he becomes very famous with
his Sandstone Retreat, what happens next
is that he falls into a deep depression.
Okay? And he turns away from the sex
cult, and I think he opens a tiger
sanctuary. Like he goes plays plays with
animals, all right? So the second
solution doesn't work either. The first
solution, which is devotion, meditation,
that doesn't really work because you
depart yourself from the world and from
yourself. The second solution, which is
that you embrace sex, you embrace the
husk, you embrace the material world,
that doesn't work either because it just
makes you even more guilty of
It makes you feel more guilt, more
shame, okay? So what's the solution?
What at the very end
of
the book Thy Neighbor's Wife, Gay Talese
proposes a solution, okay? And we're
going to read it together. But what
happens is this. Gay Talese grew up in
Ocean City, New Jersey.
He is Catholic, and Ocean City, New
Jersey is mainly Protestant. So he's an
outsider. He's Italian,
uh everyone else is white, and his
family is are immigrants, everyone else
is uh has been there for generations. So
he's always been an outsider. As an
outsider, you feel nothing but
guilt, shame, and fear.
And so after he takes this sexual
journey into the into the heart
of human darkness, into sex. Um
he returns to Ocean City and by now he's
in his mid mid-40s. And he decides to do
something really risky. He decides to go
to a nude beach.
This is something that you know, if
you're an immigrant young boy, you could
never ever dream of doing, okay? Because
you you yourself already feel you you
already fear being ostracized or being
laughed at or being mocked at, right?
There's no way you're going to a nude
beach. But Gateless is now in his
mid-40s.
He's still suffering a lot of scars from
his immigrant childhood.
But he decides, "I'm going to go to a
beach, the nude beach, okay?" So he goes
to the nude beach and he takes off his
clothes and he's there naked.
Um and everyone else around him is
naked.
Then he spots some sailboats s- sailing
across and these are people watching
them, okay? So this is society. This
represents society laughing at you,
mocking you, ridiculing you for being
different.
And what happens is that Gateless stands
up and he stares back at them.
Representing the fact that he's learned
the courage to accept who he is.
He's learned the power to see social
convention, social taboos as prisons,
okay? So this is the very last paragraph
of
uh The Neighbor's Wife.
Painted on the stern of most of the
boats beneath the declaration of their
names was the lettering of the locale,
Ocean City, New Jersey. And seated on
the decks were people wearing Bermuda
shorts and sailing caps, bathing suits,
straw hats, and dark glasses. And in
their hands they held cans of beer,
thermos bottles, transistor radios, and
handkerchiefs that they waved at the
nudists, okay? This is a lot detail. The
only way you could have have this detail
is that if you were actually one of them
on these trips, okay? So, this is
telling us that before going to nude
beach, he himself was on a sailboat
sailing like everyone else watching the
the nudists. And now he he himself has
become one of one of the nudists, okay?
There were also some catcalls coming
from the boats, whistles, and cheers.
And after watching for a few moments,
Tal stepped forward on the deck
separating himself from the other quiet
nudists, and he faced the boats
recognizing a few of the sailing ships,
and he thought some of their passengers,
okay? So, these are his friends.
All right? These are people that he's
most afraid of knowing
that he's nude.
He also noticed for the first time that
many of the passengers held silvery
telescopes and dark binoculars, and they
sat rigidly on their decks and swayed in
the water and squinted in the sun. Okay,
so there these are voyeurs. These are
people who secretly spy on peo- people
being nude. Why do they secretly spy?
Because they are afraid.
They have ego. They have fear.
They have guilt. They have shame. So,
they have to hide themselves. And so, to
show that he's not afraid, what he does
is they were unabashed voyeurs and
looking at him, and Tal looked back,
okay?
So, he's looking at directly at those
spying him and says like, "I was once
you.
I was once also afraid and living in
fear, and now I've liberated myself.
Okay, I am now free."
The question then is, how is it that
Kate Tal succeeded,
but Harold Rubin and John Wilson, they
failed?
Okay?
And it has to do with the nature of
poetry and the purpose of writing.
Okay.
So,
>> [snorts]
>> the Kabbalah
ask us, "Where are the sparks of light?"
Okay?
All right. So, um
we first have to figure out what
consciousness is.
And something that I've been teaching in
this class for the past semester is that
our consciousness is what's real. Our
consciousness
are infinite dimensions, okay? And we we
can know by by by like by using this
visual depiction where our consciousness
is spread through infinite dimensions.
Okay?
And at a certain dimension, we're all
just one
force, okay? The monad.
So, the separation is only superficial.
In reality, we're all connected in some
way.
Now, because of this, it tells us that
memories are not stored inside of
brains, but inside this universal
consciousness.
All right. So, these memories of ours
are are
stored in
the universal consciousness.
Some of our memories are so powerful,
are so great that they're shared amongst
others, okay? So, even though you
yourself
have had this memory, it is such a
spectacular memory because it's so
imaginative, it is so unique, it's so
special that it affects other people as
well.
All right. So, these are
these memories. And these are the sparks
of light.
Okay? So, in other words,
yes, the purpose of life is to find the
sparks of life of light. But what we
need to remember is, and this is what
Home Edition tells us is that we have
the the
to create sparks of light ourselves by
living great lives. What are great life?
Lives that are unique. Lives that are
filled with courage.
Lives that are filled with passion.
Lives that seek to distinguish
themselves from others.
Okay? And that's why Hal Gatewood Lee's
wrote the book Thy Neighbor's Wife.
Because he wanted to distinguish himself
from others. Because he was on a search
for the truth, okay? He wanted to like
search
for the sparks, okay? Search for the
truth, the sparks of light.
And in so doing, he himself created
sparks of light.
Why? Because he spent years interviewing
these people in a draw out the sparks of
light from the universe.
And when you do that and you can write
it down and show it to others,
then you expand the imagination
of the universe.
Okay? And this is
really the purpose of life. Why are we
here? We're here to create sparks of
light ourselves so that we can inspire
others to search for their own sparks of
light. And that is the ultimate message
of Thy Neighbor's Wife.
Okay?
All right. Well, that's it for us, guys.
All right? Um
it's been great teaching you. This is my
last class at the school.
And
this is not the end of my journey.
I will continue to teach. Uh 2 weeks
from now, I'll be teaching Dante.
I'll be live streaming Dante
uh to a global audience. And after that,
there'll be more classes.
And I hope that this is also the
beginning of your own journey
into life. Remember
that it's ultimately your choice how to
live your life. But to live a truly
great life, remember that there are
sparks of light out there, and it is
your
um opportunity to create sparks of light
in the world. Okay? All right. So, thank
you.